كثير من المقاطعه المتداوله كمان كانت
لردات فعل مجنونه على اهداف المنتخب وعلى
الفوز كمان لكن نجم ردات الفعل من دون
منازع كان المعلق العماني خليل البلوشي
اللي كان بيعلق على المباراه
[تصفيق]
الثاني وبعيده في التوقيت المناسب وبعيده
في التوقيت المناسب الى خارج ارضيه الملعب
اثنين
مقابل هدف واحد لمنتخب الارجنتين هنا في
المباراه في الافتتاحيه
[تصفيق]
يا عيني عليك
وكانه الى ايام جميله يعود لحمايه العريق
والست والله العظيم والله يا محمد كره
لمصلحه المنتخب السعودي محاوله عن طريق
اللاعب محمد جبريل لا
زال
جانبيه
مقاطع البلوشي تداولها الناس بشكل واسع
واكثر علقوا على تفاعله اولا ومهنيه
الثانيه يعني عمل شغله في نفس الوقت تحتفل
وطلع اللي في قلبه احنا بتفعل لكم تواصلنا
مع المعلقه الشهير وخصنا وجمهور تفاعلكم
بهذه الرساله من الدوحه
يا مساء الخير ساره تحيه لك ولكل متابعين
تفاعلكم وسعيد جدا حقيقه بهذه الاطلال
الاولى لي على قناه العربيه
وسعيد جدا بالتواجد معك في البرنامج همم
اولا حقيقه كل التهاني والتبريكات للمنتخب
السعودي وللسعوديه حكومه وشعبا لهذا
الانتصار الكبير اللي تحقق على المنتخب
الارجنتيني وكل التهاني لان احنا كلنا عرب
بمناسبه هذا الفوز وهذا الانتصار الكبير
اللي يتحقق امس على منتخب الارجنتين في
همم يعني واحده من اكبر المباريات تاريخيه
للمنتخبات العربيه في بطولات كاس العالم
لبعض يتحدث عن هذا الانتصار التاريخي
الكبير لان اعظم مباراه ربما قدمت همم في
تاريخ مشاركات العرب خلال منافسات بطوله
كاس العالم والبعض يعني يتحدث عن ان اللي
تحقق امس كان بمثابه انجاز كبير جدا
وشاهدنا ردود الافعال الكبيره سواء من
خلال
ال- الاعلام الخليجيه العربيه وحتى بدون
الافعال العالميه اللي كانت على انتصار
المنتخب السعودي والكل اللي كان يشيد
باداء المنتخب السعودي وروح المنتخب
السعودي اللي كانت همم حاضره خلال هذه
المباراه همم انا واحد من الاسماء اللي
كنت جزء من الحدث اللي كان موجود امس
حقيقه وتشرفت اني اعلق على هذه المباراه
وهذا الانتصار التاريخ السعيد جدا ايضا
بالفيديوهات اللي انتشرت بعد المباراه
وردود الافعال اللي كانت موجوده في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ردود افعال الناس اللي
كانت على الفيديوهات المنتشره همم يمكنك
اعاده شوي اكون متفاعل بطريقه او باخرى
دائما مع مباريات كره القدم لكن الخصوص
يعني او خصوصا مع منتخباتنا العربيه همم
نسبه الحماس تكون مرتفعه شويه ادرينالين
التفاعل لما كان موجود من خلال شوط
المباراه الاول
معنويه كبيره جدا اني انا اكون بهذا
الحماس وهذا الظهور خلال مباراه المنتخب
السعودي والمنتخب الارجنت خصوصا في الشوط
الثاني وحقيقه يعني من خلال فيديوهات اللي
تم تناقلها يعني انا كنت جدا جدا سعيد
مردود الافعال
همم امس على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يعني
ما اقدر اوصف لك واعبر لك عن مدى السعاده
اللي انا عشت حقيقه خلال همم مباراه الامس
وبعد نهايه المباراه من خلال ردود الافعال
اللي شاهدناها او اللي شاهدتها انا شخصيا
بعد مباراه المنتخب السعودي والمنتخب همم
الارجنتين همم نتمنى ان شاء الله نتواصل
افراحنا العربيه في المونديال نتمنى ان
شاء الله نحقق نتائج ايجابيه نتمنى ان هذا
الاتصال يكون دافع معنوي اكثر لبقيه
المنتخبات العربيه للظهور بشكل مشرف في
بقيه منافسات البطوله شكرا لك تحيه لك
ولكل المتابعين شكرا
[موسيقى]